looking at this figure can you tell me
the number of triangles it contains
we'll see an interesting method to find
this let's start with a simple case here
you will notice that this triangle is
divided into two parts part one and part
two
so what is the total number of triangles
here don't make the mistake of saying
two your this is the first triangle this
is the second one and this is the third
one so in totality there are three
triangles let us consider one more
triangle which is divided into three
parts parts one two and three if we
observe carefully what are the number of
triangles here
one
two
three
four
five and six
six triangles so the total number of
triangles here is six so if you look at
the pattern in the first case it's one
plus two gives us three in the second
case one plus two plus three gives us
six
similarly if we have six parts in a
triangle then what will be the total
number of triangles
correct it will be the sum of the first
six natural numbers and that will give
us the answer as 21.
please note that the type is similar the
lines are drawn from one vertex only to
its opposite side so if a triangle is
divided into eight parts then what will
be the total number of triangles let us
know in the comment section for more
such interesting math concepts please
subscribe to our youtube channel